lagodinsky sie haben gerade das video
auch gesehen dass von dem team von dabei
nie auf instagram gepostet worden ist
wie viel wie schlüssig halten sie die
inhalte die sie da jetzt gesehen haben
wir haben keinerlei grund zu zweifeln
das was die kolleginnen kollegen
wunderbar präsentieren das ist ja alles
dokumentiert ich finde es sehr
aufschlussreich wenn das bedeutet dass
wir auch beweisstücke außerhalb
russischen jurisdiktion haben und das
bedeutet auch ich sag mal dass jetzt
etwas reißerisch in sicherheit
wir können damit arbeiten und diesen
tathergang rekonstruieren und das ist
natürlich ein ganz wichtiger punkt das
wird natürlich in den russischen medien
anders dargestellt werden es wird mal
wieder darauf hingewiesen dass die
wahrscheinlich jene die diese
gegenstände rausgebracht hat einer
deutsch britische kollegin von nawal nie
etwas zu tun haben könnte mit der tat
aber das ist sozusagen das übliche die
übliche hetze und die übliche verwirrung
die auch durch russische medien häufig
geschichte ja maria pesci soll diese
flaschen von russland nach deutschland
geschmuggelt haben nun möchten die
russen
sie finden sie suchen sie gerade um sie
dann zu befragen wie die russischen
behörden selber sagen glauben sie dass
frau per scheck jetzt in gefahr ist
das wissen wir nicht
es ist allerdings wichtig dass alle die
mehr informationen für die aufklärung
vorbereiten können dass diese leute auch
sagen wir etwas stärker vielleicht
geschützt werden sollten und ich hoffe
dass die behörden die europäischen
behörden hier auch ein bisschen mehr
vorsicht walten lassen
also in oder an diesen wasserflaschen zu
alexander weine in sein zimmer gelangt
sein gibt dass irgendwelche neuen
schlüssel darüber wer die täter sein
könnten
das müssen täter oder täterinnen seien
die ihm zugang zum hotelzimmer haben es
kann also nicht einfach jemand sein der
im vorbeilaufen etwas in einfach rein
gesprüht hat das was ja ursprünglich in
diesem offenen café areal am flughafen
das verdacht verdacht sozusagen war da
oder verdächtigt wurde
das bedeutet schon vielmehr
organisatorische und kriminelle energie
und das wird immer schwieriger etwas
behaupten dass es irgendwie jemand war
der vielleicht einfach aus jux und
tollerei da einen scherz sich erlaubt
hat also es verdichten sich aus meiner
sicht hinweise dass hier mit großer
organisatorischer planerischer energie
vorgegangen wurde und dass da zumindest
staatsnahe oder staatliche behörden mit
involviert worden sind auch im
europaparlament fordern sie jetzt
konsequenzen für diese taten haben eine
initiative ins leben gerufen unter dem
motto das fass ist voll was genau hat es
damit auf sich
wir wollen das hier konkrete
konsequenzen gezogen werden aus der
situation und nicht nur aus dass sie
dort sonderwagen erwarten ist einfach
nur ein letzter tropf in dieser sehr
langen in dieser sehr lange sequenz von
menschen die entweder angegriffen oder
vergiftet worden sind oder gegen sie
gehetzt wird in russischen medien
da gibt es ja auch opa ganzer kampagnen
wir wollen dass die europäische union
konsequenzen zieht das bedeutet ganz
konkret projekte wie nord stream 2
müssen gestoppt werden oder sie müssen
noch mal auf dem tisch das ist ja nicht
das einzige projekt also große
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit projekte
großprojekt benennen
die zweit und der zweite punkt
bekämpfung der korruption viele der
gruppen politikerinnen und politiker die
auch alexei navalny entdeckt hat mit
seiner organisation
die haben vermögenswerte in der
auch das müssen wir genauer überprüft
also wir haben ganz viel zu tun aber das
erste und das wichtigste wir brauchen
eine internationale untersuchung und
aufklärung des falles und wir sehen
jetzt an diesem beispiel dass es auch
außerhalb russlands möglich ist hier
beitrag zu leisten und ich erwarte dass
die eu-behörden hier in diese richtung
ermittelt mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur bei bet schau dich hier das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren